questo è il nostro mondo il mondo che
vogliamo conoscere che vogliamo
conoscere per avere una possibilità di
vivere meglio di vivere più felici
perché questo è quello che vogliamo
tutti ma per poterlo conoscere
dobbiamo studiarlo e per poterlo
studiare
dobbiamo misurare il mondo che ci
circonda
quindi il mondo che noi vogliamo
conoscere il mondo che però vogliamo
studiare e studiare il mondo vuol dire è
misurare il mondo misurare il mondo è
quello che è stato sempre fatto dai
cartografi la cartografia si è da sempre
occupata della misura del mondo della
misura del mondo prima e della sua
rappresentazione dopo perché lo possiamo
conoscere questa misura del mondo per
tanti secoli è rimasta invariata vedete
due immagini molto diverse tra di loro
dal punto di vista temporale ma le
misure del mondo venivano fatte sempre
da terra dopo di che a partire
dall'inizio del secolo scorso abbiamo
cominciato a volare gli esperimenti dei
fratelli wright all'inizio abbiamo
cominciato a prendere le immagini del
mondo da sopra di noi
prima gli aerei poi i satelliti 1957
sputnik adesso sta iniziando una nuova
era l'era degli amman lievi al veicolo
wavi quelli che molti chiamano in modo
più semplice e droni ma torniamo per un
attimo ai satelliti che sono la realtà
di oggi l'ultima immagine che vedete in
basso a destra è un satellite e
satellite worldview 3 world 3 è un
satellite che vola abbastanza basso vola
circa 600 chilometri di altezza rispetto
a noi che a molti sensori e tra questi
sensori un sensore particolare che è una
camera fotografica è una camera
fotografica con la quale come dicevamo
le scherzando
la terra si fa i suoi selphy e queste
immagini sono immagini del tutto
particolari e spettacolari perché da
quell'altezza riusciamo a riprendere il
mondo con un dettaglio dell'ordine dei
trenta centimetri quindi un qualsiasi
oggetto sulla superficie della terra che
è più grande di 30 centimetri viene
ripreso da worldview però world ju non è
l'unico satellite che monitora la terra
qua vedete un'immagine della terra
circondata dai suoi satelliti
artificiali che sono operativi quindi
non sono tutti i corpi che orbitano
intorno alla terra in cui dovremmo
aggiungere idee brees i satelliti che
ormai non sono operativi e così via sono
solo quelli operativi ognuno di loro ha
moltissimi sensori e quindi c'è un
monitoraggio in tempo reale della nostra
terra
però quello che dobbiamo dire che queste
immagini non sono immagini
immediatamente utilizzabili da noi per
mappare il mondo perché per quanto
abbiamo del computer molto intelligenti
computer non è ancora e probabilmente
non sarà mai intelligente come l'uomo
per cui abbiamo bisogno ancora degli
uomini che mettano i loro occhi e la
loro mente su queste immagini per
poterla interpretare allora la
cartografia è cambiata tantissimo negli
anni per quanto riguarda le tecnologie
ma è cambiata anche moltissimo la sua
mission
all'inizio la cartografia una
cartografia costruita per scopi militari
o per scopi catastali quindi per poter
mappare il mondo e imporre della
tassazione legata alla proprietà poi a
partire dagli anni settanta le cose sono
cambiate e si è cominciato a utilizzare
la cartografia anche per scopi diversi
ad esempio scopi di pianificazione
progettazione del territorio e così via
ma la vera rivoluzione è undici anni fa
2004 nel 2004 nasce questo progetto che
si chiama open street map è l'ideatore è
questo allora ragazzo che vedete qua
steve cost
allora neo laureato di informatica
ayusya
university college of london assieme i
suoi amici
steve comincia a portare avanti questo
progetto che è il progetto della mappa
libera del mondo
l'idea fondamentale di steve e dei suoi
amici idea che attecchisce
immediatamente a livello globale
soprattutto grazie a un movimento al
movimento dei sistemi informativi e
dell'informazione geografica libera e a
codice aperto open source che fanno
subito proprio questa idea e da pochi
contributori all'inizio del 2004 si
passa oggi a un numero di contributori
che supera i 2 milioni due milioni di
persone in giro per il mondo che mappano
la nostra terra
quali sono le idee fondamentali di steve
e di open street map
la prima idea è che l'informazione
geografica quella che una volta era la
cartografia che adesso
detto in termini moderni si chiama
informazione geografica informazione
geografica sta diventando pervasiva
sempre più gli eventi fenomeni che
accadono a livello mondiale sono eventi
e fenomeni che trovano la loro
contestualizzazione loro significato si
sono collocati dal punto di vista
spaziale applicazioni pratiche
la navigazione con le nostre macchine
che ormai facciamo con i navigatori
satellitari e con le mappe la
navigazione individuale che diventerà
sempre più importanti i servizi basati
sulla localizzazione nei quali siamo
solo all'inizio ma la seconda idea
importante è che se noi vogliamo poter
utilizzare questi dati se vogliamo che
questi dati siano dati liberi
allora questi dati dobbiamo crearceli da
noi quindi a questo punto la moto forte
di open street map che open street map è
la mappa creata da persone come te per
essere usata liberamente da chiunque nel
mondo e come si può creare queste mappe
lo si può fare individualmente ma è
molto più divertente molto più bello
farlo tutti insieme
e allora possiamo organizzare quelli che
sono i muffin parties e quindi questa è
la prima parola che voglio che impariate
mappe in parti si vuol dire ritrovarsi
tutti assieme e mappare mappare con uno
scopo ad esempio quello che vedete in
questa immane
è un map in parti a osaka per costruire
la mappa della resilienza quindi
cittadini scienziati amministratori
membri della protezione civile locale
così via si trovano girano per la città
individuano quali sono i punti che
dovranno essere utilizzati nel caso di
emergenze quali sono i punti che
potrebbero presentare difficoltà e così
via creano la mappa della resilienza il
motto è mappare il mondo però voglio
raccontarvi anche un'altra storia a
questo punto la storia di haiti del
terremoto di haiti
quando un terribile terremoto distrusse
haiti e allora a questo punto si doveva
intervenire la per poter intervenire
bisognava conoscere come muoversi in un
territorio la cui morfologia era
cambiata
a seguito del terremoto a questo punto
alcuni gruppi legati open street map
ebbero questa idea ottenere delle
immagini satellitari ad alta risoluzione
per mezzo di intercessione di
organizzazioni internazionali mettere
queste immagini sulla piattaforma e di
open street map che una piattaforma dal
punto di vista tecnologico molto
avanzata perché infatti vi ricordate che
steve cost è un informatico vi ricordate
che tutto questo nasce nell'ambito del
software geografici libero e a codice
aperto quindi la piattaforma è molto
complicata ma il suo utilizzo è molto
semplice può farlo chiunque non bisogna
essere dei nerd la piattaforma è a prova
di bambino o meglio forse a prova di
nonno allora a questo punto vengono
messe queste immagini nuove di haiti
modificata su questa piattaforma e viene
lanciato una colla a livello mondiale
tutti i volontari si mettono a mappare
in poche ore la mappa di haiti è pronta
una mappa importantissima che serve per
capire come muoversi sul territorio e
che serve in definitiva per salvare
delle vite
dopo questo si sono costituite task
force in giro dappertutto nel mondo e
ogni volta che c'è un evento
catastrofico tutti i volontari si
mettono a mappare per poter costruire il
nuovo assetto del territorio ma non
dobbiamo andare tanto lontano per fare
queste cose
nella immagine che vedete è descritto
quello che è successo qui proprio a como
al politecnico di me
questa primavera a seguito del terremoto
del nepal
ci siamo trovati in tanti abbiamo
imparato come mappare tutti insieme e
abbiamo contribuito anche noi a creare
la mappa che è servita a tutti i
volontari sul posto per poter
intervenire ma in questo siete molto
fortunati devo dire perché casualmente
questo the dix viene a coincidere con
l'inizio della settimana della
consapevolezza geografica una settimana
che è stata decisa da tutte le
organizzazioni di open street map che
gravitano intorno a open street map a
partire dalle 15 ci saranno tutta una
serie di eventi in giro per il mondo
almeno 100 eventi di mapping che noi
chiamiamo ma patton e questa è la
seconda parola che voglio che impariate
il muppet non vuol dire trovarsi tutti
in un posto ognuno con un computer
perché questa è la cosa fondamentale per
mappare tutti insieme
quindi se siete interessati giovedì
prossimo non tanto lontano da qua a
milano il politecnico di milano faremo
un ma paton faremo una paton e di cosa
ci occuperemo in questo ma paton se
saremo così sfortunati che ci sarà
qualche emergenza dovremmo occuparci di
questa emergenza ma se invece saremo
fortunati e in questi giorni non
succederà niente non rimarremo inoperosi
perché c'è un altro bellissimo progetto
al quale potremo contribuire che si
chiama missing maps
il progetto missing mappe un progetto
che si occupa di quelle aree del mondo
che sono aree dimenticate ma che sono
aree fragili fragili a causa delle
catastrofi naturali o di altro tipo che
possono abbattersi su queste aree ma di
solito sono anche le aree più povere del
mondo e quindi non hanno le
infrastrutture la strumentazione come
abbiamo noi
allora a questo punto è quello che
possiamo creare in questi ma paton sono
le mappe di queste aree dimenticate del
mondo per essere pronti nel caso dovesse
succedere qualsiasi evento catastrofico
questa comunità questa grande comunità e
generosa comunità formata soprattutto da
volontò volontari non si occupa però
soltanto del mapping
in preparazione dei disastri o durante i
disastri vogliamo fare qualcosa di più
vogliamo anche avere un occhio positivo
rispetto a quello che succede ma allora
ci sono anche molti altri modi per poter
contribuire al ma ping del mondo per
mancanza di tempo ve ne cito soltanto
due
il primo la biodiversità biodiversità
soprattutto in ambito urbano non
possiamo non dobbiamo pensare che la
biodiversità sia soltanto in posti
lontani che non conosciamo
esiste anche una biodiversità molto
vicino a noi e noi dobbiamo imparare a
conoscere apprezzarla e tutelarla questo
progetto urban gene un progetto del
politecnico federale di losanna ed è un
progetto nel quale si chiede a tutti i
collaboratori è sufficiente avere un
computer per poterci accedere di
inserire quelli che sono i dati sulla
biodiversità nell'area intorno a losanna
il secondo progetto di cui vi voglio
parlare invece è un progetto di casa
nostra ed è un progetto a questo punto
invece di tipo culturale e turistico ma
un turismo di tipo diverso un turismo
che si chiama slow tourism lo slow
tourism è un qualcosa di simile allo
slow food è un utilizzo del territorio
che sia un utilizzo consapevole
quello che vogliamo fare e non aggredire
il territorio ma muoverci in modo lento
sul territorio
muovendoci in modo lento sul territorio
quindi camminando andando a cavallo
andando in bicicletta si ha modo di
guardarsi intorno e guardandosi intorno
si ha modo di capire quelle che sono
tutte le ricchezze del territorio che ci
circonda
magari delle piccole ricchezze o magari
delle ricchezze che sono ricchezze per
noi per i nostri amici sono valori per
noi e magari altri non hanno considerato
oppure si può cominciare a vedere se ci
sono delle emergenze sul territorio e
comincia a segnalarle tutto questo viene
riassunto in un progetto che è un
progetto alla sua fine alla sua fine che
si chiama il progetto i cammini della
via regina la via regina è un percorso
storico che
a parte dall'italia per andare verso il
nord europa e via regina è una strada
che già esisteva in epoca romana e che è
stata percorsa da tantissimi tantissimi
personaggi a partire dalla via regina
che corre lungo la sponda occidentale
del lago di como si dipartono tantissimi
sentieri e percorsi che vanno verso la
svizzera percorsi transfrontalieri che
sono percorsi ricchi di cultura e di
storia attraversati nel tempo da
pellegrini da contrabbandieri da persone
normali come noi in questo progetto via
regina abbiamo voluto aggiungere anche
una parte di mapping collaborativo
quindi esiste una app che tutti voi
potete utilizzare andando sul sito di
via regina per andare in giro in questi
territori aggiungere le vostre
informazioni sul territorio in modo tale
che queste informazioni siano
immediatamente mappate e visibili da
chiunque su un sito internet dove
abbiamo una mappa collaborativa che
cresce di giorno in giorno
in conclusione come vedete c'è tanta
possibilità per poter partecipare a
questi progetti di mapping assieme a noi
una volta i cartografi erano quelli che
partivano andavano in giro per esplorare
nuovi mondi e cartografare nuovi mondi
adesso i cartografi possono stare a casa
loro possono stare nella loro città e
portare a casa loro e nella città il
mondo e perché lo facciamo lo facciamo
perché tutti insieme vogliamo disegnare
un mondo che sia più libero condiviso e
partecipato
allora se qualcuna di queste storie vi è
piaciuta quello che posso dire che
potete venire con noi voi sarete i
prossimi cartografi perché adesso tocca
a noi